we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
this may be the the most chaotic
voicemail we've ever received
this is a guy who i guess has been
calling he says i haven't gotten back to
him i'm not aware of ever having
received a call from this guy
but
he repeats just about every
recent covet lie i can remember
there's a kid crying in the background
what sounds like his female partner
is yelling things to to him to say this
this almost is performance art of some
kind of avant-garde nature let's listen
to it together
david pac-man this is billy harrison
again i see you still haven't uh all
right let me rephrase that i see you
still haven't
so there's the kid in the background
okay just chaos uh responded to my
voicemails either you're scared or
i'm not aware of any voicemails and i
obviously you know we i have a thousand
voicemails to listen to right now we
obviously can't respond just like i said
you spread
misinformation
and you don't know what to say back to
me like i said anything that you say i
can debunk you you spread missing makes
you lie math do not work so we have
peer-reviewed
rct's
masks work
that's a lot
vaccinations don't work that's a lot
vaccinations do so is well
he sounds linguistically confused he's
saying vaccinations don't work that's a
lie
anyway vaccinations obviously work very
well you're 97 times more likely to die
of covet if you're
unvaccinated the election was stolen
that's true
the election was not stolen there's not
even evidence that a single state was
stolen donald trump
was the greatest president of all time
that's true no evidence of that for sure
everything that i could say i could back
up what about you
it's funny how people think asserting
something is backing it up yes
i know i gave you my number and
everything else
so for me and you to go live
on your channel on your little show
and debate
and i can prove you
prove to you that you're you're you're
bull
and that's all you do is spread
misinformation
live i i like the woman in the
background yelling lies and then he says
lies yes that's exactly it what a
chaotic situation huh
yeah you'll take everybody else's
voicemail stupid [ __ ] about you leaving
the country i don't give a [ __ ] whether
you leave or you stay or you the the
person in the background feeding him
lines is i mean you could if this was a
skit you could not script it any better
oh well we need to make fun of it
like i said all this you talk about
trump sort of playing trump bingo why
don't you debunk that he's saying saying
nope that's a lie
this is what really happened that's what
we do you can't
you sit there and play trump bingo
what about biden and the democrats and
you can sit there and say that you're
not a democrat all you want to i mean
it's it's quite i've it's quite
literally the truth i've never been a
democrat you're a [ __ ] democrat oh
okay a liberal democrat
a communist socialist
democrat meanwhile the left is like
david you really should be a socialist
why aren't you a socialist
and if you
ask ask me why and ask me the policies
like you like to have
everybody else
get me live on your show and i'll make
you look stupid about the communists and
socialists i would love it for someone
to make me look like a communist like
the first question would be
tell me one
communist policy that i support anyway
that guy sounds like he's got a lot
going on i won't deny that it might be
actually fun if he called in
um so hopefully he will he will call in
during live calls we're going to talk
about what is happening with the beijing
olympics on today's bonus show
very low viewership and also
uh the the quarantine hotels are being
called quarantine hell
it's crazy what is happening we will
also talk about alcohol returning to
flights
in the u.s and concerns among flight
attendants groups about it i would be
concerned we'll talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com we will speak to you
then